un mes después del paso de la tormenta
Julián la cicatrices aún son visibles en
Honduras en este campo Las lluvias
arrastraron todos sus cultivos y la
tierra sigue cubierta de agua fangosa
ahorita estuvieramos ya ya preparando ya
preparar la tierra para sembrar de nuevo
pero como se vino está llena ya nos
sembramos y no que vamos a esperar a que
seque en El Salvador estos agricultores
tampoco pueden cosechar maíz un alimento
esencial para sostener a sus familias
esperan la llegada de ayudas de parte de
las instituciones para sobrevivir antes
de poder retomar la producción
desde lo único que nosotros vivimos Y si
por decirlo así si el gobierno o algunas
instituciones no nos apoyan nos vamos a
ver más afectados no más allá Pues
porque ahorita no tenemos que darle el
ganado ni ni que comer pues los
agricultores guatemaltecos comparten la
misma angustia el Ministerio de
agricultura contabilizó 60.000 tareas de
cultivos afectados en diferentes niveles
por la tormenta tropical Julia estamos
bien asustados porque no hay donde nos
vamos a ir porque ya no tenemos terreno
para comprar no tenemos pisto para
comprar un pedacito en tan siquiera un
sitio las crisis me dio ambientales
están en el centro de las preocupaciones
de organismos e instituciones un informe
del Banco Mundial alerta que los
impactos del cambio climático podrían
empujar a 132 millones de personas a la
pobreza en los próximos 10 años